So if you actually wanted to,
build this,
you have to implement an algorithm for
doing it.
Now, I tell you, I took this algorithm
from, I think, their claim slides,
they're on the web, that he took
from somewhere else, etcetera.
So I don't know for
sure that this algorithm is the one
they used, but it sounds pretty good.
All right, it is,
it's similar to what you would do.
So, first thing you do is you
project out these dots, and
you just detect them.
So you detect these speckles, and
you label all of them as unknown.
I don't know their depth.
Now what you start doing is you
randomly select a dot that's,
that's labelled as unknown.
And then you take this windowed search,
all right,
doing a normalized correlation,
and along a scanline.
That is, that really should
say along an epipolar line.
I know exactly where to look, okay,
and I check for the best match.
And by the way, I have to make sure
that that best match is good enough.
If that best match is not so good,
I mark that dot as invalid and
I start looking for new dots again.
But, if my first match is really good,
I start doing what's
called region growing.
I start looking around the,
that neighborhood for
matching other points against
the known pattern, okay?
Oh yeah, by the way,
what am I correlating?
I know the pattern I'm projecting, so
I've got my little local pattern of
what's called pseudo random speckle
points, and
I just correlate them around.
And so,
pixels nearby are added to a queue.
For each pixel, I initialized its offset
looking for it from the one I just had.
I search around a little bit,
see if I find a good enough match.
If so, I label it as matched
with it's offset, its disparity.
And then I look for its neighbors and
I add them to the queue.
And I stop doing that
when that queue is empty,
because I've finished
using this anchor point.
And I go back again and I, I, I,
reinitial, I pick another point and I
stop when all the points are labeled as
with a known depth or marked as invalid.
So what makes that work is that I have
this, semi, this pseudo random pattern,
so any little patch is not, can't be
matched everywhere but is matched or
just in one place well
along that epipolar line.
I know those patterns and so I can
just drive that search very quickly.